la mère fois que j'ai prétendu qu une
publication scientifique fortement
fondée sur la paix value avait une
conclusion plus probablement erronée que
valide à l'aide notamment d'un calcul
bayésiens en particulier ioannidis et
johnson et de nombreux autres
statisticiens affirme qu on en est
arrivés ici parce que trop de
scientifiques comprennent mal ou abusent
de la notion de paix value et ignorent
consciemment ou non les conditions
nécessaires pour un rejet fiable
hypothèse aujourd'hui on va essayer de
clarifier encore un peu plus ce jugement
sévère des statisticiens nous attaquant
cette fois ci à la logique
alors pour clarifier ce n'est pas la
logique en tant que tel qui pose
problème
quoique la logique est en fait loin
d'être aussi logique que ce qu'on
pourrait croire comme on a déjà
longuement parlé dans une série
précédente
le problème fondamental c'est la
validité de l'application de la logique
en sciences et en particulier à la
notion de réfutation de théories en
particulier la réputation de théories
suit la logique du raisonnement par
l'absurde ainsi dit-on parfois une
théorie scientifique t doit faire des
prédictions x autrement dit si tu es est
vrai leur on doit observer x note cela
parfois tu es un pic x mais alors si on
observe une donnée dès qui n'est pas x
alors nous semble justifié a rejeté t
autrement dit on a alors non x implique
monte ainsi la science par réputation va
chercher à collecter des données des
epci des est égal à nohic ce concours a
que tu es est faux et doit donc être
rejetée en termes logique un tel rejet
de thé suit la règle du modus tollens et
ça en gros ça revient à admettre
l'équivalence entre une implication et
sa contrat poser en particulier en
mathématiques ou du moins en
mathématiques dite classique
on utilise souvent cette équivalence
entre tes implique x et non ils
s'impliquent noter pour prouver des
théorèmes ces contrats poser est quelque
peu perturbante de prime abord il ne
semble pas c'est évident que tu es un
pie x et non explique notés sont
équivalents en fait intuitivement quand
on n'est pas habitué
ça peut paraître même faut par exemple
par un raisonnable de dire que sachant
que 1 est un nombre positif
la proposition un plus un égale 2
implique de est positif est une
proposition vraie cependant la contre a
posé deux est strictement négatif
implique qu'un pussin est différent de
deux semblent moins convaincante de
prime abord
bon après je veux dire qu à force
d'entendre ça quand on est mathématicien
ou
par l'accepter en particulier oui en
mathématiques on considère souvent que
si à est une affirmation fausse alors à
implique b est toujours vrai quelle que
soit la valeur de b nous le martèle même
tellement souvent que beaucoup de
mathématiciens ont fini par considérer
qu'il s'agissait là d'un axiome
indétrônable de la logique voir qu'il
s'agit d'une vérité évidente mais le
problème est en fait plus profond que
cela considérons la phrase suivante si
la france avait gagné l'euro 2016 alors
les poules auront des dents
est ce que cette phrase vous paraît vrai
si vous vous efforcez d'appliquer les
règles de la logique
il semble que la réponse devrait être
oui certes la conclusion de cette
implication paraît fausse mais sa
prémisse fosses où il car pour rappel la
frappe de gignac a malheureusement fini
sur le poteau
or on a vu qu'une implication dont la
prémisse est fausse et vrai perturbant
non la logique nous suggère de conclure
que oui tout à fait si la france avait
gagné l'euro 2016 alors les poules
aurait des temps faut-il accepter cette
bizarrerie de la logique
faut-il reconnaître que la logique c'est
pas logique ou du moins pas intuitif
mais bon vu que nos traditions de
soissons est pourri autant faire
confiance et la logique
faut-il vraiment déferré notre jugement
à la logique
la logique mérite-t-elle nos crédence ou
n'est-il pas un cadre de pensée dont la
validité épistémologique serait
supérieur à la logique
bon vous l'aurez compris j'ai une idée
de réponses à fournir à ces questions
qu'ils aient à financer du bail à nice
mme oui il me semble que la logique
passe à côté de quelque chose
d'important quelque chose de crucial
quelque chose de fondamental pour penser
juste et cette chose c'est le conseil
principal de l'éditorial des
statisticiens sur la crise des
statistiques
acceptons l'incertitude nous vivons dans
un monde complexe et il faut toujours
envisager la possibilité que l'on se
soit trompé malheureusement le langage
binaire de la logique est bien trop
rigide pour parler adéquatement de
l'incertitude
un langage naturellement adapté à
l'incertitude semble préférable
et justement le bail à nice mme l'objet
de cette série de vidéos
c'est tout simplement faire du langage
des probabilités le fondement du savoir
en particulier si la phrase si la france
avait gagné l'euro 2016 alors les poules
auront des dents ce faux c'est peut-être
que malgré tout il n'est pas
déraisonnable de penser que la france
pourrait
avoir gagné l'euro 2016 après tout cette
connaissance se fonde sur notre mémoire
et nos mémoires sont très faillible et
puis qui sait si le portugal ne sera pas
un jour disqualifié pour je ne sais pas
une affaire de dopage
la france pourrait avoir été déclaré
vainqueur par défaut de l'euro 2016
alors oui clairement la crédence que
j'aime le fait que la france a gagné
l'euro 2016 et ultra négligeable mais
elle n'est pas non plus tout à fait nul
dès lors je peux envisager l'implication
si la france avec annie l'euro 2016
alors les poules auront des dents
sérieusement et là encore je vais
commencer par traduire cette phrase en
termes probabiliste ça donne la
probabilité que les poules et des dents
sachant que la france a gagné l'euro
2016 est quasiment égal à 1
et là tout de suite ça paraît très faux
en langage probabiliste la phrase si la
france avec emi l'euro 2016 alors les
poules auront des dents paraît très loin
d'être vrai car la probabilité
conditionnelle associés ne semble
vraiment pas être proche de 1
ok la logique n'est donc pas le bon
langage pour parler du monde mais est ce
si grave de l'appliquer au cas de la
science est-ce que l'équivalence entre
une implication tu es un pic x et ça
comptera poser non x implique non t'es
doit être remise en cause pour répondre
à cette question dans le cadre du bail à
nice mme il nous faut d'abord traduire
ses implications logique dans le langage
des probabilités et y ajouter le grain
de sel probabiliste adéquat pour prendre
en compte notre incertitudes dès lors
l'implication t implique x devient
probabilité de x ça chantait est grande
tandis que non x un pic noté devient la
probabilité de à sachant non x est
grande ou à l alternative à thé est ce
que le fait que la probabilité de x ça
chantait et proche du rhin implique que
la probabilité de à sa chanson x est
également proche de 1
l'équivalence entre une implication à
grandes probabilités et ça comptera
poser à grande probabilité de mortel
valide
l'une des plus grandes puissances
intellectuelle de mes réflexions
bayésienne fut de découvrir que la
réponse à ces questions peut être
déduite de la formule deux pays pour y
arriver je vous propose d'étudier la
formule de baisse des cotes pour le cas
où la donne et observé des est égal à
nohic ce n'est bien l'équation suivante
la cote a posteriori de thé contrat est
égale à la cote a priori x le rapport de
surprises
et pour plus de détails je vous invite à
les revoir les épisodes 14 et 15 ans et
alors oui en effet si la probabilité de
la donne et sachant la théorie est égal
à zéro c'est à dire si la donnée est
infiniment surprenante alors la cote a
posteriori de thé sera nulle ou pourra
alors rejeter t l'équivalence entre
implication et comptera posé reste vraie
cité n'a aucune chance de prédire des
cependant en pratique notamment à cause
de toutes sortes de bières expérimentaux
possible mais aussi tout simplement
parce qu'on effectue des prédictions
probabiliste sur des données
statistiques
la probabilité de la donne et sachant la
théorie n'est jamais exactement égal à
zéro conclure de manière si binaire
c'est ce qu'on pourrait appeler le
sophisme de la logique
en général les lois de la logique ne
s'applique pas dès lors tout ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que la probabilité de la
donne et sachant la théorie est très
faible
la donne et des est peut-être très
surprenante ça chantait mais elle n'est
jamais complètement inimaginables en
tout cas alors ce côté est une théorie
qui envisagent la possibilité d erreur
de mesure des fausses données et de
toutes sortes de biais de sélection et
dans ce cas non la cote a posteriori de
thé ne sera pas nécessairement très
faible en effet pourvu que la donne et
déçoit tout aussi surprenante selon les
alternatives à athée ou pourvu que tu es
est très crédible
a priori la théorie t pourrait même être
très crédible un posteriori aussi il est
en fait de nombreux cas où malgré une
donnée dès hautement improbable la
théorie t demeure extrêmement crédible y
compris sachant d vous ne me croyez pas
prenons des exemples dans l'épisode 12
n'a parlé du cas de la parapsychologie
ou une donnée dès était hautement
improbable
si on supposait la théorie t qui
correspond à l'état actuel des
connaissances en physique
les données des furent talent une raison
suffisante pour alors rejeté la physique
probablement pas pourquoi parce que la
physique était hautement probable
a priori elle demeure hautement
probables a posteriori aussi autre
exemple dans l'épisode le sophisme du
procureur qui soit dit en passant est en
fait le même sophisme que le sophisme du
logiciel dont on parle dans cette vidéo
hygiène mentale a donné l'exemple du
procès de salies clark en supposant la
théorie t de son innocence
les a donnés des qui correspond au
double décès de ses nouveau-nés et
fait hautement improbable néanmoins
encore une fois à cause de préjugés
raisonnable à avoir sur l'innocence d'un
individu ces données ne suffisent pas à
rejeter l'innocence de salies clark
ces deux exemples montrent très bien en
quoi des préjugés très marquée pour des
raisons justifiées peuvent conduire à
des contrats posées dont le statut
épistémique est en fait très distincts
de l'implication original quand on a des
préjugés marqué à avoir l'équivalence
entre implication et comptera poser
s'effondre mais ce n'est pas le seul cas
où ça arrive dans l'épisode 11 de la
série sur l'ia hygiène mentale et moi
avions donné l'exemple du loto en
supposant que le loto n'est pas truquée
ni biaiser la probabilité de gagner au
loto qui a aujourd'hui consiste à
choisir 5 numéros parmi 49 et un numéro
chance parmi 10 est égale à une chance
sur 19 millions
imaginons maintenant que je gagne au
loto est-ce qu'il faut alors rejeté la
théorie t selon laquelle le loto n'est
pas truquée ni biaisé et bien il faut
bien reconnaître que la donne et des qui
dit que j'ai gagné au loto est hautement
improbable selon cette théorie
puisqu'elle est d'une chance sur 19
millions ce qui correspond à plus
extrême qu 1,5 si demain qui est le
standard de la physique des particules
selon ce standard
il faudrait alors rejeté la théorie t le
problème c'est que même si le loto était
truqué le fait que je gagne demeurera
surprenant en tout cas selon moi et en
supposant que je n'ai pas moi même
truqués deux lotos wicca dans la formule
de bayes ce qui importe n'est pas juste
la surprise de a donné des ça chantait
mais c'est aussi et surtout le rapport
de surprise de la donner des en
supposant t&d alternative at et plus
généralement raisonner en termes
d'alternatives semble vraiment important
pour ne pas donner d'importance à des
données qui sont surprenantes
selon à peu près n'importe quelle
théorie imaginer qu'un homme sorte de
chez lui à exactement huit heures 54
minutes 13 secondes les 903 2
millisecondes
quelle est la probabilité de cet
événement clairement il est très
improbable qu'il sorte pile poil à cette
heure là à la milliseconde près pour
essentiellement toutes les théories tu
es un tant soit peu crédible
a priori la vraisemblance de cette
donnée d est infime
cependant ce n'est pas parce que la
donne ait des est invraisemblable
sachant une théorie t que tu es n'est
plus crédible sachant des variations de
la crédence de là
or it et ne dépend en fait pas
uniquement de la surprise de la donner
des sachants t elle dépend des rapports
de surprise de la donner des sachants la
théorie t par opposition à sachant d
alternative crédible à thé
bref j'espère vous avoir convaincus
très souvent non la logique ne
s'applique pas en particulier une quasi
implication n'est absolument pas
équivalente à sa quasi contre a posé
pour raisonner avec l'incertitude
certaines lois de la logique sont en
fait parfois très contre-productives
en cela il me semble adéquat de parler
de sophisme de la logique pour raisonner
avec incertitude il semble préférable
d'adopter le langage des probabilités
comme le propose le paysagisme 1ère fois
on avait parlé d'un modèle très
simplifiée des publications
scientifiques pour essayer de voir
quelle était la crédence à voir en une
publication scientifique et en
particulier avait conclu que bien
souvent fait les publications
scientifiques ne semble pas conduire à
des résultats crédibles les a notamment
à cause de la priory qu'on a souvent sur
les publications scientifiques qui parce
que on veut aucune publication
scientifique soit cité après avoir été
publiés fait qu'on a tendance à
favoriser la publication de résultats
davantage surprenant et du coup
davantage peu crédible a priori les
écureuils fait leur marque que du coup
ça paraît assez difficile de défendre
des conclusions scientifiques comme par
exemple le fait que l'homéopathie n'a
pas d'effet au delà d'une placebo en
tout cas si on est balayant la question
importante imposée après avoir lu une
étude scientifique ce n'est pas
qu'est-ce qu'il faut croire du coup
c'est comment je dois déplacer mon
curseur de turing quelle est l'ampleur
notamment de ce déplacement est le truc
c'est que chaque étude scientifique va
dépasser légèrement ce curseur et s'il
ya 100 études scientifiques qui font
chacun dépassé ce curseur d'un beat et
bien ça fera un déplacement de sambi
même si vous étiez 20,8 d'un côté vous
finissez 88 de l'autre et un curseur
hier à 80 beats et donne une crédence
mais alors vraiment vraiment vraiment
quasi sûr et là on peut vraiment parler
d'eux au delà de tout doute raisonnable
bon ça ça pique un petit peu moins
myopathies oui j'ai rarement aussi vous
invitera à parler un peu plus de tijd
effet parce que un médicament peut avoir
un effet mais si cet effet ça un effet
qui est à peine perceptible pour une
personne parmi 1 million est ce que ça
vaut vraiment le coup de dépenser toute
votre attention tout votre argent et
tout l'argent du contribuable pour cet
effet qui est vraiment minime
même s'il existe
c'est très discutable et vous encourager
à parler un peu plus de taille d'effets
spéciaux knicks demande aussi devant
toutes ces difficultés finalement à
tirer des conclusions d'études même
scientifique est ce que finalement on
n'observe pas une énorme étendue de
notre ignorance et est ce que tu
pourrais pas être triste lorsqu'on se
rend compte de cette étendue de notre
ignorance je pense que c'est vraiment un
sentiment qu'on pourrait largement à
voir parce qu'on a tendance à valoriser
énormément le fait de savoir d'avoir des
connaissances et d'acquérir la vérité du
coup quand on voit que en faux sur
nombre de choses on se sent peut-être un
peu perdu et très loin de cet objectif
alors je peux témoigner de mon
expérience personnelle moi
personnellement une attitude par rapport
à tout ça c'est au contraire j'ai appris
petit à petit a trouvé ça vraiment
génial d'observer toute l'étendue de mon
ignorance puisque ça montre toute la
marge énorme de progression que je peux
faire et comme j'aime le sentiment de
progresser le fait de toujours mieux
comprendre des choses
ben en fait ça me rendent plus excité je
voyais eu quelque chose c'est un autre
défi fabuleux à relever et du coup j'ai
juste envie de me lancer dedans avec
tout plein de curiosité
il ya plein de choses à découvrir et ça
me rend ultra curieux donc moins j'aurai
transfère a trouvé ça vraiment génial en
fait d'avoir une énorme étendue de mon
ignorance et je vous renvoie vers la
vidéo que j'ai fait
la conclusion c'est vraiment quelque
chose que je ressens vraiment quand je
me rends compte qu'un problème est
beaucoup plus compliqué que ce que je
croyais j'ai tendance à trouver ça a
fait assez assez génial surtout si ce
problème est important
alors je fait sans doute partie d'une
extrême minorité avec ce sentiment
d'émerveillement devant l'étendue de mon
ignorance et vous pourriez trouver ça un
peu difficile d'avoir ce même sentiment
que celui que j'ai hélas je vous renvoie
vers une vidéo que j'ai fait ou j'ai
parlé du fait de choisir nos émotions
est-ce que la tristesse devant l'étendue
de notre ignorance est vraiment une
émotion qui est désirable qui faudrait
elle vraiment à voir qu'on voudrait
vraiment à voir où est ce que ça ne
serait pas mieux finalement d'être
pleins de curiosité face à cette étendue
de l'ignorance et de motivation face aux
défis à relever pour réduire cette
ignorance
il me semble que assez clairement évolué
à être curieux et motivé que triste et
je pense que c'est quelque chose qu'on
peut travailler chez nous c'est à dire
que si on fait l'effort de se dire que
c'est il ya plein de choses à découvrir
d'avoir ce sentiment de curiosité
on peut finir par vraiment l'adopter soi
même et j'espère que ça gênait cette
vidéo est devant peut-être un certain
pessimisme par rapport aux sciences
qu'il n'y ait des vidéos précédentes la
prochaine temps on parlera de caisse qui
devrait être publié en sciences en
particulier pourquoi filmant le fait
qu'il y ait des résultats aux fidji
récente n'est peut être pas
nécessairement quelque chose de si
indésirables si vous avez aimez cette
vidéo pensez à la ligue et à la
commentaire partagé pensez à vous
abonner pour ne pas voter dans un
épisode d'un seul coup par perdre
j'espère qu'il me serait là la prochaine
fois exemple que vos ancêtres il ya 4000
ans et plus construire ça c'est trop peu
vraisemblable
donc ce n'est pas les humains qui ont pu
construire sa sophisme du procureur
moi aussi je trouve ça étonnant 140
mètres de haut mais ça aussi c'est
étonnant ce n'est pas une meilleure
explication que mon cousin du bout du
monde m'appelle juste le jour où je
pense à lui c'est trop peu vraisemblable
il n'y a pas de coïncidence donc la
télépathie existe sophisme du procureur
moi aussi je trouve ça étonnant on
s'appelle presque jamais il y aurait
quoi une chance sur un million
mais ça aussi c'est très peu
vraisemblable
ce n'est pas une meilleure explication
qu'un nuage de poussière cosmique sous
l'effet de la gravitation forme ça un
monde propice à ma petite vie fragile
c'est trop peu vraisemblable il s'est
donc ça existe sophisme du procureur
mokssit je trouve ça très étonnant la
façon dont se forment les étoiles et les
planètes mais ça ce n'est pas une
meilleure explication tout ce
vocabulaire de la récitation ou de la
contradiction est assez déplacé ses
pertinentes ont des sciences formelle
comme les mathématiques la logique on
peut réfuter une conjecture
mathématiques par exemple
mais pour les sciences expérimentales
les observations font plutôt quelque
chose comme augmenté ou diminué la
crédibilité de telle ou telle hypothèse
où théorie